donc ça c'est la bizarrerie qu'on fait
toutes les semaines cette semaine c'est
des tripes à la mode de caen
à peine âgé de 24 ans est déjà chef
cuisinier à versailles depuis un an et
demi axel s'active à faire découvrir le
patrimoine culinaire français au
monument café en revisitant des plats
traditionnels
cette année c'est la première fois qu'il
propose une démonstration au salon de
l'agriculture
pendant ce temps-là vecteur pour
présenter notre cuisine à base de
produits ile de france pendant qu'on va
réaliser des préparations préliminaire
et ensuite on sera plus sûr du dressage
et de la finition sur le lieu du du
salon donc les enjeux pour pour un
restaurateur comme moi d'être au salon
de l'agriculture c'est le moment de
mettre en avant
notre savoir-faire notre restaurant ya
pas de stress particulier pour nous
c'est plus du partage donc et les
échanges avec les visiteurs donc c'est
vraiment un moment de détente ça nous
sort de notre quotidien au restaurant
nous retrouvons les deux acolytes porte
de versailles à paris pour cette
démonstration ils ont élaboré leur
recette
au menu champignons crème de bris
oignons et même une pointe de citron
on travaillait production au regard de
manger on est présente aux gens on fait
une petite présentation et puis on va
dresser dans des verrines un travail sur
une bonne partie de ce lundi après midi
environ 300 verrines ont été dressés les
visiteurs font la queue pour y goûter
tout en puissance avec le brie de melun
aux herbes au départ réhaussée par la
chaleur et on va dire adoucie
par la compotée de de champignons et
d'oignons produits locaux et savoir
faire authentique deux ingrédients qui
ont su séduire la clientèle
après quelques années d'existence
l'établissement ouvert deux autres
antennes à angers et chambord pari
réussi